okay so my name is Aaron okay I I love
you Jess yeah and what I do is I've
shipped various products of UGS crypto
trading platform travel industry and yes
I organized a few Jess meet up and also
co-organized the react.js meet up I like
to try other frameworks also to convince
myself that view GSS nice yes okay so no
thanks and my teaching assistant is a
budget okay he's actually my colleague
he loves UGS also but also everyday he
works on react by day yes so he builds
web components for internal apps he
trains gives night classes in a company
I work with Seneca key we also have some
help us from the view GS meetup group
Schilling and Eugene over there yes so
if you have any help just raise your
hands and ask them yeah they will help
okay so if you are stuck please please
raise your hands please
okay you wanna have to move on okay next
slide okay so the workshop goal we do
not have any agenda okay we just want to
meet hopefully these are your
expectations which is to speed up your
learning about next yes okay if you know
some view or react is good if you don't
how you can ask around
okay boss I think and most of your here
no view or yeah yes okay hopefully
there's some real world ready framework
and tasks that will perform here okay
yes so there's some unique content is
known in Google yep so you can write it
later
yeah so you can share this after that
it's okay it's fine
okay hopefully that's something you into
next okay pair programming or is welcome
yeah
and then the materials available yeah so
later will flash it up again okay so a
quick one what is not GS so it's
basically a framework for building view
GS applique
if you know what this next Jas is for
for react Nux GS is basically the
similar so a framework yes so what is
this framework I'll explain further on
after that okay thank you welcome yeah
okay so why view GS okay so a few things
that that we want to just show us
okay react so we have three very popular
frameworks yeah it's a built by somebody
from Facebook so it's obviously
influenced by this thing called xhp
which is some XAML component framework
for PHP which I don't know exactly what
is this but you can go and look at the
Wikipedia on it yeah so problems with it
that we found when working with react
where I found when working with react
and a few others is like for the
higher-order components when you have a
lots of it
it's like back to the object-oriented
programming where you need to debug and
it's very difficult to find out where
things are okay next
okay angularjs many breaking changes
okay next yeah yeah oh yeah one more
thing the RX GS actually is very
fantastic thing but they use it
everywhere so it's not really good
because this is a very good tool but
just too good yeah okay
so view GS okay what's so good about all
right firstly it's a it's supposed to be
faster and smaller than the other tool
and the is the most standards-compliant
of all the tree like if you go into web
components you see this thing called
slots and all these things you when you
go to view GS and you see the slots
things they are very very closely
related yeah you can do a lot other
things also like the CSS the transition
so these things are all pretty
straightforward in view yes yes okay so
but whether you use view angular react
or even am
smell of vanilla yes you need to know
about these four things single page
application server side rendering study
sites and progressive web apps okay
so anybody who does not know these
sportings
oh no right yes okay so the a
progressive web app is something by
Google where you actually the word
progressive means you slowly slowly
improve on the website so you like in
some sort of where you can load up all
the assets yes all the SS and that's
yeah that's the caching strategies yeah
yeah the manifest files to load up all
the assets the caching strategies and
also the intersecting the fetch so that
you can sort of like Bill app on the
phone that can work in offline mode and
yeah and that's what the in shortener
progressive web about okay so maybe I'll
just explain a bit more further on this
tree so single page applications is what
you usually build it's a 1 HT m fo and
very big JavaScript inside server-side
okay so this one would take a long time
to load if it's a very big move for the
bigger application the longer time to
load for server-side rendering basically
the server is the one that pushes out
the web page so the house actually
smaller when you surf and you serve them
Hey okay ah yeah so just Wi-Fi password
this year download this repo okay I'm
just getting started
okay so server-side rendering is is
rendering the pages bit by bit
anybody use server-side rendering okay
good so yeah then yeah so probably
you'll be a refresher when I go through
because a server-side rendering there's
a lot of things to take care of whether
you are rendering on a server or on the
client
and you can get into trouble if you
don't understand the thing we'll explain
later can then the last one is static
sites static sites are like you're all
old days where you have many HTML files
many JavaScript files yes okay next
let's move quickly okay so it's our
application framework next what max is
okay so for next GS that's basically
less boilerplate code to write
everything's organized for you like you
don't have to to write the routers out
for all your routes
thus storage the sorry just the v8 store
is so-so the abstracted it out so you
just put in each file for each of the of
each of the view ex-mo juice I think the
Sangamon let's go to the next one okay
yeah you can easily create the different
type of websites that spin earliest SPSS
R and static sites okay so what's the
difference between SSR and the static
websites which is using nuts generate to
generate it so this is quite important
so SS re are basically less serving up
pages one by one like PHP like I
explained earlier okay it has access to
things like your request header info
because it's going through the server
yes then for next January basically they
pre generate everything so you generate
all the HTML files okay and then after
that everything is busy you load the
photo browser and you work from there so
I think the best thing to do now is to
show you the table of what is happening
which is the best part gets screwed up
as a table next right
your computer can see oh okay oh okay
ah okay okay sorry for the technical
difficulties very quick we'll fix it
yeah I'll leave it there okay okay
next slide oh this one are you know yeah
okay next slide okay okay so this is the
comparison for all these three okay so
for such engine optimization SP a is
poor because you see very little
information on the pitch it's all being
rendered by the JavaScript okay for
server-side render it is good because
you render the information and any push
it up and then the search engine
actually can pick up those things static
websites execute exactly the same how
about a time to first paint okay so for
SPS because you have to load the bigger
application again the slower it is so
but for SSR instead it's sizes up is
faster definitely deployment very easy
for single page applications just you
can serve it from the s3 or from Netley
fire or Google okay by the way if
anybody needs help to set up or anything
just raise your hands the assistants are
sitting behind it okay with the green
color kick behind the shirt okay
deployment for SSR is a bit more
involved because you need the server to
serve the things so if you need to scale
up we need to scale up the server's but
for static sites is again similar to the
SPS so four point seems fifth point
dynamic routes
okay so SPS and SS are basically they
serve up the dynamic routes but on a
static sites because you generate the
pages so if let's say one of the pages
is not Wow
you will get a not found error and what
happens is that if we like website
property guru where there's a slash and
then there's a property name and I'm
thousands of properties in Singapore you
cannot be generating a page for every
single one of them so in this case you
will get a 404 for the static size
unless you generate those things but
there'll be a way to handle this and
I'll show you how to do it in this
workshop yes then next is the DEF
complexity okay SP a and static sites
because it's all happening in a browser
so you don't have to worry all the
things that work in a browser like the
windows event listener you will all be
okay but for SSR you really need to be
careful because if you render on the
server side and you call some thing that
is in the browser like window dot event
listener is bye-bye yeah you see the
error page yeah
500 error it should be a fun error then
uh last one a pwe okay so I both of them
can handle so any questions on this one
no questions okay so now go to why I'm
ever kidding static sites but you can
still build in PSP a if it's a internal
app the step size is not very very very
very big there's no server site similar
to SP a but that's less complexity in
the development and also the deployment
actually I'm repeating why I said just
now so skip about the libraries we can
go back let me see anything else
okay next yeah this is early on he saw
now what would we build today no nuts
yes we'll cover as much nuts as possible
we will dissect one of the modules okay
because there was some problem that I
faced and the normal module couldn't fix
it so you have to go in and see how to
fix it
we all look about these things like the
Knox view
layouts and a compote the other nuts
views and their layouts the options and
a life cycle okay explain this one in
detail later SSR and static size issue
so later on we'll go and see how the
website explodes okay then we'll install
simple REST API so that you can do the
some API and that's where we are fixing
the problem for the module yeah so
before we start let's do this we
installed a back-end okay so have your
clone the repository okay so if you have
not clone a repository and follow the
commands down here and once you do NP
and run def port 3000 it should what
so maybe the my assistants will go
around and help then I will take about
two minutes two minutes run in it DB is
to initialize the database
it's a back-end oh [ __ ] oh no no sorry
ignore the repo up there in order pull
up there yeah it's a stuff in the
backend folder it's in the back and go
to the backend folder do the NPM install
I took out yeah it was derived from the
project on top and took out all of
things up there yeah okay so
yes git clone yes the whole thing yes
yeah I think that note Mon you don't
have to because I've updated the package
sorry you just ignore the note 1 yeah ok
anybody needs help
okay too fast too slow no right okay too
fast let me know okay too slow so let me
know okay done okay anybody have been
finished okay
okay okay okay yes you can help your
neighbors tool if they need help
okay I'll just go round one last time
okay good good okay Ken Oh run death run
there okay you need the power is it you
can use those yes yes oh yeah wait
wait is it a small winner oh yeah you
just need that one to plug in you're
going you're the big one
no it's not enough power because it's my
book is bigger fighting you should put
it there so causes somebody might this
is not a good thing - yes that one down
there any more space okay
Kennedy yes is fine API / yes sorry haha
okay the API roots don't care yet okay
it's wrong is API slash slash of slash
login an ape slash API slash
off slash longer but don't care about
this is okay once you see the console
listening at port 3000 you are fine okay
listening at 40,000 a fine don't need to
yeah and we've got test out the post
I forgot the parameter sir
yes this is correct yeah it will give
you back something you've just post
rubbish to it
okay who's not ready
okay okay I will start carry-on in about
30 seconds anybody not ready oh you're
not ready not ready I using no I don't
think so Kenan why what's the error
again and you see SQLite databases okay
okay that is definitely a problem okay
give it you have him that thing okay Ken
are we ready okay
yes yes let's nice to see the thing
listening and poetry thousand is fine
okay don't worry about rest
okay so kidonia I'll move on but the
systems will help okay so not to worry
okay so this bottom left is what you
should see this black color thing
listening on port 3000 that's all and
later what we'll bill is this a login
and logout only yeah but yeah you can
add more things up today okay so let's
get started with nuts now okay first
line npx create - knocks - Jess conf
that's all run the first line no oh get
off the back end folder sorry go one
level on top and then run the command
actually can run in the backend food of
some but it not been good yeah but
thanks just I exit the go one level up
of the back end and then run create
knocks nuts
yep okay so while it's oh so you ask you
a few questions okay the important thing
is server framework none because we are
not gonna do any deploy any express or
anything yet select Axios when it comes
to option do not select any linter or
prettier because later if you cut and
paste the code you might have some
problem if my
man is not the same k Knoll internal PT
adjust in at the X Yas then UI framework
is beautifying and then the rest I think
should be okay oh no 10 okay SQLite
right okay okay but okay the note 12
people right go to package.json delete
the SQLite Nikesh and do a NPM install
SQLite again see maybe it's not version
I'm using but okay don't worry if you do
not if you can install a back-end right
is still fine
okay okay okay who's still not ready
okay yes okay don't read the Sun we have
another some more time okay so once you
finish all the options settings the job
then we just wait there okay okay
piece work hold on okay okay so for
those with no 12 keep your fingers
crossed with the SQL is so you might you
might be yes yes okay
sorry those yes those give me notice we
have SQL like three problems on the back
end
delete the SQL like free from the
package.json file and do a NPM install
again yes yes yes okay sorry yes
sorry god what is it ah yes or no to
package this on delete this one and
install it again yeah okay exit back can
do Dan yeah okay yes let me do something
okay I know some of you have not got
this got this far okay yeah yeah I'll
write it here
sorry other okay this one all in small
letters
okay you're here Jesse okay that's the
most important part okay okay we'll give
another two minutes we'll move on okay
don't oh you are still on time yes sorry
okay
front end directory is the answer yes
it's not everything is there so we are
now doing the front end from scratch
yes yes and okay so well the rest of you
are waiting those who are ready right
there's this package a wipe out this
does this package you can use one
command you run the front and the back
end together because right now you need
to go to the back end folder MPA run
death front end folder MPN run death so
this package concurrently okay
if you don't know just go and look for
it
once you install it you can use it to
run your front and your back end
together and save you a lot of time
we set up again in dashdb yeah it's the
center MPM run - yeah package.json
everything is the packages on yeah
actually the rim is - I forgot already
yeah okay yeah okay one minute okay so
ah I'll move on okay
okay I'm moving on haha okay so what you
see inside is the project structure for
Knox okay
I think you can see ya so the my can you
do a npm run death inside the front end
directory
I'll sorry instead just come beside yes
confer you will have some problem
Hey you will have some problem you yes
because you are using pot 3000 nuts is
using port 3000 so first lesson Fornax
you're gonna do is configure the pot
okay so inside GS call there's a folder
nax dot config dot GS open it okay and I
will write the property that you are
keying to change the port number
okay so server okay this is the property
server and then actually you don't need
a host just port we can use 8080 or
anything that you have free on your
computer
okay so change to this and then do the
NPM run def again okay so where is jazz
corn or back-end the command to run the
application is the same NPM run def okay
okay
okay so your hot module reloading if you
change let me go back okay so for those
who are free I will explain the project
folder or next okay you just need to go
to the file explorer view get to the GS
con folder there are a few folders
inside there the first one you see is
assets so you place all the assets like
pngs
even some JavaScript files inside that
your utility files what happens inside
the assets folder is that the web pack
will compress and whatever they do with
it okay it's the first thing or CSS
source or inside there the next part is
the components this way you put the
components that you build for the
application okay then next is the
layouts okay this is the layout where
you like for some websites your login
page you have a certain layout you don't
have a nav bar you don't have a menu
after you login all the pages have a
never menu and so on so you can specify
different layouts for your various pages
here we will touch on this okay okay so
for the next installation and running
even it helped dusty around here I will
go on with the others
okay so chaos in middleware first pages
is where all your pages for your web
application live so you can have your
log in log out page inside their
products page and then you can even have
subfolders for each page like products
then sub products and so on
so it's a basically a treeview so how
many levels your URL parameters you want
to go is mirrored by this page you don't
need to setup any routing or anything
this one will actually do it for you and
how to specify a dynamic route we'll go
to inside K doses pages is very
important and there's a lot of things
going inside the pages where the nuts
options are yes which might spin okay
plugins is basically like your Axios
when you install or like momen or
something and you want do something
before that you put it inside the same
for the middleware static it's all your
static content which will not be web
packed and the store is the view X store
which is like reduction so on ok so this
is the Knux structure every Nooksack
application follows this structure yeah
so now we come to two things there are
two things in Knox plugins and modules
that's actually a big difference between
them say plugins can be something like
external libraries like your moments
your low jet low - and beautify which is
a UI is also a plugin ok so weapons is
that there's some initialization code
where you want to set that theme of the
plug-in like for team of the beautify
you create a beauty 5 file in the
plugins directory and in Knox config
there's also something that that tells
you there's a property called plug-ins
and it has the beautify inside to tell
where to search for the file inside of
plugins folder I think it's better you
look inside the the plugins folder to
see if there's anything there may not be
anything actually right now ok ok so
anyway plugins is very simple it's just
some external libraries that you add
into the view knocks yes ok the other
thing is modules k modules are more
involved because they are extending the
core functionality of knacks GS so
there's a lot of things that some quote
or some operation inside this modules as
tightly linked tunics GS so this
actually is a very big topic which I
can't cover because I'm also not capable
to cover because I've not build a module
from scratch yet but we are going
dissect the module okay so we have
already in stock one of the modules
which is Axios okay is already done
let me look at the code okay - oh can
you help me look at your thing to open
up so I can see the code yeah because I
okay can I have a look sure thanks okay
okay there's nothing the block is in
page yeah okay so nevermind nice yes
okay okay so is how you know that is
already installed inside Knox GS is that
you look at the Knux config file okay
that's actually a module call
Axios and also for beautify inside o
beautifies module now okay okay so today
we'll learn about the authentication
module and we'll go into it okay we have
not installed that one yet okay so the
important thing is the next config file
where all the configuration takes place
okay the so me don't you
oh thank you thank you okay but now the
screen has disappeared okay now let's
move on
hey wait I know what to do hi okay it's
coming down again so I guess minimize
this one right okay sorry
okay oh thank you
it's like number one okay mm okay so now
we'll go to the first module they were
gonna install if you need a reference oh
gosh is so small okay
here let's go to you just open up this
page later because we're gonna dig into
the code inside here uth next ah thank
you okay so you th dot Knox object store
up will be the game to this later so
we're gonna install this module now so
just do a npm install at Knox GS / off
or you can do NPM I just a small I is
faster
okay npm i okay we already installed X Y
so there's no need to do it
okay then once you finish installing the
end module you go to Knox dot config dot
GS and ad at the ethnics GS / off to the
modules property okay so there's a
modules property inside contacts config
GS you just add the package name at
noxious English order I know it doesn't
matter yeah oh okay yes if you got an
error about the store being missing just
create an index dot GS file inside the
store folder that's all it can be a
blank file yeah I don't know why it
happened before I saw you just create
the file index dot J's and everything
will work fine okay so if you get an
error about a star index dot JSP file
and leave it it should work after that
right yes okay
yeah
all right good catch
okay so we have only installed it we are
going to start to use it soon
okay let me I do not use them back for
some time yes like my okay thank you
okay so now that you have put that thing
inside the ha
inside the nuts doc config yes he will
now configure the when I'll configure
the module so let me go to the website
now okay okay I think if you can't see
don't worry help me to stop okay okay
hey what is it okay
suddenly oh okay nevermind do you see a
readme - 1 dot MD file inside GS conf
read me - 1 MB file ok you scroll to
data items one two three okay item tree
is the one where the settings for the
nuts config of the off module is there's
this off property you can copy and paste
it into the nuts off
Wow okay lucky we didn't it's quite
small you have the code editor somewhere
you just do a code I don't know what we
started yes I don't know what this is I
know is this too small because I can
make it larger okay yes oh okay Jesco I
know yeah but there's too many crap
inside here okay this one okay this is
I'm scared of the timeline yes this is
it Russia
okay this one okay okay okay yes Wow
okay it's nobody still you zoom in some
more because behind really I can't see
okay Samar Samar
yes uh screwed ow yes they're off okay
so yeah so we're gonna do the local
strategy which is basically you sending
your email and password and get a token
from the back end okay
the back end how it works okay you can
figure out yourself later
yes so basically there are two end
points one is login which is slash off
slash a slash API slash of slash login
the other ones logout and then the last
one which is user slash API slash off
slash me is to get the user information
okay yeah so this is basically how you
configure it the token required true
token type error this is all inside the
documentation for knock stuff here so
still pretty straightforward
zooming nothing yes yes all the copy and
paste that you need to get things
working yes yeah so because we realize
that if it's the type of loan right what
did you really you can't see anything I
can't see anything
okay okay
everyone good yes just the off block and
I'm putting in the config okay case
yeah so sorry about going through this
but it's gonna get a bit tougher okay
next slide next slide
yeah yes okay
oh I think you mean okay so this is just
for knowledge will see inside a coat
later okay you can set up the
authentication Pearl Rob so inside view
GS files that's the strip and inside the
strip that's the export default and here
we see a middle way off so once you put
the off thing inside this is a protector
route that means um if you're not
authenticated by the off module you get
redirected to where you where you
configure it in Knox JS conf if for now
we are using the default which I think
you redirect back to the the slash dot
slash yes
Oh back my mom okay okay so that's per
page you can also do it globally that
means you make every route must be
authenticated and that is done in the
next config inside a router property can
you set the middle way as off so every
year out will be authenticated if you
want a particular out not to be
authenticated you go to the page and
then you give off force yep so this
straight from the documentation yeah ah
in a middle way okay you can actually
put in a bracket if you have more than
one middle way there could be a
internationalisation middle way or some
other things so if more than one you put
us the thing in an array otherwise can
put it in the just in a string okay guys
I think a lot of you're confused on what
fell recording here so the front end
is natural solution it has been in here
application up and running we created a
new project with the MPX who in dust and
wonderful believe meter we're reporting
on that so just to clarify that okay
thank you okay so now we'll go to the
first we'll go to the store alike Creek
I see a copy copy and paste it so we'll
go to the default view page we are gonna
replace everything that's inside there
okay so if you go to number four of the
readme - 1 dot MD ok you copy and paste
the whole thing over replace the whole
default dot view inside the layouts
folder so that's the layouts folder
inside that's the default dot view file
wipe it out and replace it with this
okay what is inside the file is a
beautify text HTML text yeah beautify
order beautify for the front end making
it look nice okay that one I think can
read more about it later I will go
through the authentication part
okay okay yeah
yes so the important thing is cut and
paste make sure you can run then we'll
make let you understand in a while okay
then my my teaching assistants or
helpers can help to help you to
understand okay is to 905 yeah
yeah okay this a lot of coat here
because you are building a menu
interactive the Neph bind everything
case so if you have a record along right
I think we would take that see how has
to code so we are here to learn NOx so
you just copy and paste don't worry can
understand it later okay so now I
explain to you the important things
inside here okay no no no yeah and the
slides okay so the first one dollar dot
off
dollar dollar state dot logged in k
dollar dot off is actually the module
the off module they're using so they
have a dollar off dot whatever lots of
things that relates to the the off
module and this logged in is actually
deflect to indicate whether the person
is logged in or not okay yeah it doesn't
contain the user details is just whether
the person's logged in or not and okay
the state right
this module actually comes with a built
in storage so it will store your your
information you can store it inside the
view X store the local state the second
one is in a session cookie and let that
one is in the local storage so it
actually does everything for you
behind the scenes so later on I think
when you do the login if you
successfully log in you check your
debugging console you should be able see
the the information inside yes okay next
is dollar of dot user so this one is
contains the information that we get
from the API route where we get the user
information that's slash API slash off
slash me okay and very important inside
an layout page that's this thing called
the Knox tech
so whatever is inside the layout is the
parent and this thing is all the pages
that you define inside a pitch folder
whatever will appear here and which
layout to use is inside a page so inside
your web page the the file that's
actually distinct only are only as one
of the property so you specify the
layout you are using for this is default
and in nuts the layout for the default
is called default okay yeah so it will
go to the default pitch
later we'll build another layout okay so
any questions any questions can run can
run cannot run okay cool yes
ah
okay okay okay okay good we have still
some time okay so okay yeah
imagine you have a login page with no
nav bus and you have login picture if no
net bus that's the layout after you
login you have a nav bar okay so that's
another layout so you create two layouts
one with one without the nav bar one
with the nav bar so then you create your
pages which is rests inside the layout
okay so let's see you have a sign-in and
sign-out sign in and sign up page you
want to use the empty layout so you
inside the sign-in and sign-out page
there's a layout property you just
specify the name of the layout file that
you create and if it's the other pages
those days after you login your products
your users or this and you want to use
the nav page ok you can specify the nav
pitch inside the inside that you can
specify the nav layout inside the page
the key word is layout layout so inside
the page dot view you have this thing
called layout ah I know because you
haven't gone to the page yet okay we'll
go to the page and then maybe it's
easier for for us to see all okay
this woman has given birth yeah
so if anyone what you have before the
nest and after the mast you can define
your layouts so first we have my column
down like this where the first pitch is
that's just instant the password and
once you log in we have a different
layout we can just reuse this yeah yes
yes yeah so there's some huh
oh thank you okay so there's some magic
going on in the nuts
okay Snorri slowly we will get to learn
about it okay let's go on to the next
page the public page which everybody can
see before logging in so next we go to
item 5 on the readme - 1 MB item 5 this
is quite short okay you can cut and
paste the thing in to this page where
you create ok so the pages folder pages
folder you that's this file called index
dot GS if it's not oh sorry index dot
view if it's not that created if it's
they replace the whole thing yes it
should be there right I think they're
just replace the whole thing inside
there
ah typo okay yes it's a no sorry it's
that fine okay yes yes it's a typo yes
okay that's good with slight so
everything working copy and paste
everything will Qingdao explain what's
inside that pitch I'm sorry I can
explain furthermore but maybe once I
finish with whatever I need to teach I
can explain more on those things so okay
yeah already done npm run def okay then
inside there that's the dollar of dot o
should be dollar state okay and then
login so this one it just the same as
before it tells you where there's login
or not yeah okay so this just a public
page is very simple so it index kb you
create a public page again okay this is
where we'll do some some things inside
okay so copy number six and file name is
create a public dot view inside pages
okay
yes create a public dot view file copy
and paste yes I know it's a lot of copy
and paste now but it is building up for
the next step Oh Oh to ten okay
okay this is the peach later we will
test some problems with server-side
rendering yes sorry peach down to the
default I guess up up up sorry up up up
up up up up okay zoom in a down bounce
right now oh yeah yeah okay so see down
here middle way oh okay so this pitch is
actually suppose to be authenticated
okay but because these options I put off
as false the public can actually so is
actually not authenticated so if you are
not authenticated you can still go in
what else there's something very
important oh yeah so this layouts right
you do not see any layouts property
inside here if they do not see they are
using the default dot view layout okay
yep so when when you see this page you
will still see the I think the default
patients got up the menu bus and
everything yeah okay so I think okay so
I said I'm the public page okay go back
to the slide okay we'll go on to the
next one
yes okay we will go on to the private
pitch which is only after you login you
can go in so this one is number seven
yes case we are sorry it's secure yeah
you can call it secure if you name it
some other name right inside the inside
the layout stock page you have to also
change the route to be similar to this
so if it name it slash ABC you go to the
layout dot default dot view file look
for slash secure and change it to slash
ABC yes oh sorry sorry sorry yes yes
sorry sorry we've secured it okay starts
go to 8 plus no because I go to 8 I'm
sorry go to 8 yes go to 8 and then
create this pages log in dot view yes
sorry number 8 no because I changed
halfway because the lock in was more
involved yes there's a lot of things
inside there
oh you can do both yes ok do both Lubo
what's the other ones the key all right
secures it okay let's just do both okay
create the login to view create secured
of view copy and paste the code inside
good suggestion thank you yes so anytime
you find you need some way to improve or
speed up
I've not improved approach what
processes please go ahead yes
important thing is the code can work
okay once you're done we need to do some
things here
okay wait first okay so that's this
thing okay fetch user okay this is the
one that fetches user information okay
let me look at the okay so once you
already go to next config yes and look
at base URL okay
you should be pointing to the localhost
port 3000 on sorry basically Axios base
URL that's Axios and then base URL at n
ug moment
hey so just make sure that this is a
localhost 3000 yeah the back end okay we
can move on to the next slide okay
oh great we have a break okay so that's
uh this thing called custom elements is
a web standard for those web components
one of the four pillars of web
components so that's this website called
custom elements everywhere calm and it
tells you which is the weather they are
compared how compared well it is okay
view and angular is still there you can
look at all the other frameworks down
there okay react yes is really the worst
70% it's anyone
okay just to get our mind off a bit okay
less detox to the mind a bit and why any
questions we can take questions here
no questions nobody nothing so the
important thing is that whatever you
copy and paste it will work and then
figure it out later yeah
yes sorry yeah yeah you have yes yes
okay thank you
you guys thank you okay sorry the timing
is it oh yeah yeah yeah we started 15
minutes oh okay but I didn't explain
much fun of you
because you want to talk about it
because I'm not really about it no it's
really like templates
you okay
[Applause]
No
okay so now we're gonna go to the fun
part okay so if you look at the
documentation for the authentication for
next it's a very easy actually because
all you need to do is call this login
with thing and then you specify the
strategy like local there's two local
and off too so if you use oauth2 you can
do a github Google whatever okay so we
can do this very easily username
password next slide now okay but now we
hit a roadblock okay okay yes so what is
my problem
any guesses is ready I just log in and
log out but why can I use it
sorry Tory that's no wrong answer it's
okay
there is part of the problem that's part
of the problem oh okay very good
actually that is very close okay
very close very close getting closer
okay I know it's not that one because
the one is always probably it's always
forces okay yes okay uh sure okay to Fe
I got a app that needs to FA Google off
you know this I can't do it
I checked the the stack overflows to
everywhere
nothing okay so time to dig into the
modules okay so now we all go into the
off module okay now teach you how to dig
inside you go let's go to github or you
can search for Knox off okay once you're
there go into the package.json file
because from there you can see where the
module was start off okay okay very okay
plus plus plus plus plus plus yes I
think you have to bigger I think
plus plus plus yes okay package.json
there's this thing called mean property
inside there inside you should see a lip
slash module slash index dot JSP is the
starting point of everything where you
dig it's not just for off module some
other package they use even in react or
whatever is I think so yeah
so let's go inside the package.json okay
it okay we also we go into the lip
module index dot JSP min a bit more okay
let's look at the packages plus on top
sorry the constant okay nothing here
that tells me anything
go down a bit more okay okay this lip
root tells you where the library root is
which is actually top
okay now mangoes throw down some more
nothing looks interesting yet
okay setting default strategies we know
from the documentation that's a few okay
that's this copy plug-in okay ah wait
okay so copy plug-in is inside the one
of the inside the import where they are
surrounding kingdom I will scroll down
and you see validate options okay
this is just yeah but it's just copying
the your other options inside
okay so ah okay not copy core yet you
can scroll down some more
okay copy plug-in ok scroll down
okay okay scroll down nothing
interesting okay scroll down
don't worry if I forgot I have the
answer somewhere resolve scheme Wow
okay okay wrong okay screw up I think
it's somewhere copy plug-in where is it
okay wait source go down a bit it's
wrong okay so there's something say here
okay options go to the sly la
X look I remember digging through this
okay let's see okay copy plug-in yes
this is a copy plug-in okay on top okay
so this sauce resolve liberal it goes to
this plugin GS so there's a plug-in
system inside view I suspect something
is going on inside
so we'll proceed to the next foul
which is plugin but you know the folder
the route yeah okay let's go to the
slide first yeah so we go to the module
plug-in so now I'm our index go up and
go to the module plug-in yes this is the
one
yes okay so this looks like something
interesting CTX inject and the dollar
sign off do you see that also
so this doing something important and
that's a new of where it creates the new
instance of this off so this is quite
important there must be something inside
here okay let's see okay so it
initialized okay there's something
inside here what is in the notes okay
yes so the off is obviously sorry the
input of good or import of go to the
import offs okay so this top line is
telling me that's importing something
here which is very important so I'm
gonna find off GS power so go back to
the module and then go to lip-lip
because it's not here there's somewhere
where they actually link it to the off
look at the call I think's in a call
okay so going through off GS now okay
so exactly we see there's a the context
and options that's passed in when we
knew the off object let's scroll down
some more okay strategy is here scroll
down some more
yes some oh hey strip strategy and same
scheme others endings yes Lester I think
because this no of Oh
login with login you if it's inside the
documentation so this login wave cause
something inside here called login so we
go into the login which is just below KN
is looking for this dot strategy logged
in so he's got to do is something in the
strategy okay because now here can see
us a rap blog in this strategy logged
login okay so we go to find another foul
let's go back up again so yes there's a
strategy somewhere or something go no
get out the folder yes
okay get off call I don't think it's
here nope
oh just let me show you something okay
story it's not GS go inside here this is
where you see that the IP working with
the view X store okay so they actually
work with us you can stay store the
authentication stuff inside the local
state inside cookies and sex strategy so
everything on side a you don't have to
bill your own you want to add any more
code okay let's find the off strategy
this strategy so so schemes keep yeah it
sounds like it so yes best guess ah so
there's two schemes local and off to as
in a documentation let's look at local
see what happens
local hey scroll down ah okay set token
this one oh it works with xeo so this is
way that she says the authentication
header okay okay good the song you may
need it later scroll down some more we
look for the login ah login okay so if
you didn't specify your endpoints inside
a config file they will return bye-bye
okay so you need to specify let's look
at some more okay so login / packed okay
oh okay
so weapons is that login also thus
effects user the problem with that the
OTP is that when I do the login first
I haven't cleared the OTP so I can't
fetch the user so that's a problem
so I need to do is I need to do a login
without fetching the user once I clear
the OTP then I fetch the user okay so
how do we do it sorry what yes we have
to do something with the functions here
which is the which is the login and so
on we can actually make use of all these
functions down here K which I will show
later yes let's go back to the slide
then you can start working on a solution
okay there are some tips though you can
console.log inside the source files to
see what's happening okay to learn more
about the library that's one thing when
you are dig in and you use finding files
a lot to find things okay so basically
what is important is that set token that
we need to call if we are gonna do all
the things for ourselves to set the
authentication header
there's also a set token that is inside
of the GS we need to call this one
little one can dig in yourself this was
that setting or the local storage and so
on okay so here's the I explained before
for fetch user
this should fail for the two FA and only
after you clear the two FA then you
fetch the user okay so we are gonna fix
it instead of waiting for somebody to
fix this problem okay so how we gonna
fix okay next slide
I don't previous okay so we're gonna fix
it ourselves we are used existing
library sauce we are not gonna do any
[ __ ] or whatever we just use the
functions that's existing inside there
which is inside the login dot view which
you have very copy and paste right okay
so
oh I need a punch password okay so maybe
we can go into the login dot view file
now to see how it is actually done okay
just I have copy and paste the login dot
view right so this is actually the
answer screen side there okay one thing
to notice this one I did not put in any
ot P but you can still log in and log
out without the OTP pad if you want to
see the whole OTP thing in action
that's actually my repository actually
has it yeah another repository
okay so login dot view okay so I scroll
down a bit yeah look in that view
okay so what happens is that once the
person clicks the login button
oh you wanna login button there okay
bite me to zoom in you can see okay so
once you click the login button okay it
will go to a method inside view just as
this income method which will do the
login okay so what happens is that I
okay I actually didn't use those
endpoints that specified in in the
enough knocks off because I'm doing it
here so you send a post to the back end
okay using an email and password and
then come out okay for the example the
username and the password is test tes T
okay okay maybe you can try later so the
thing is after the thing comes back
successively I set the token in the
local storage and so on and I set the
token in the Axios okay and then after
that I get the me result of course if
you are doing the OTP you will not be
getting your me user you'll be going
again to get your OTP verified before
you get a user and once you get a user
back you can use the off function set
the off module set user to set the user
so this is where you get just now the
dollar dot dot dollars did not use the
user information and once you're
authenticated we can push you to
whichever page that you want to okay
which is secure pitch so if you want now
you can actually test out by typing the
username and password test test to go
into the secure pitch and there'll be
some information that is displayed in
the secure pitch actually this quite
fast
yeah so yeah it's done already
everybody good so far
okay okay you okay
okay so we have a why yard checking it
out we have a shot shot break again Hey
Oh typo changes I can change set
interval
okay so set interval this javascript
command okay
how you use it in react hawks okay when
you induce effect and you need to set
interval that's this whole block of code
that you need to do in order to set the
interval okay
in view GS is just this one line down
here on the mountain who came out that
means the JavaScript is ready the page
is loaded there javascript is ready yes
this for the realist component did mom
okay so that's the why I tree before you
just to react okay and then there's a
very long explanation on why this is so
yeah so we'll take another short break
okay okay okay
anybody still need no help
yes yes yes okay
oh my some reason my back end is like
sorry okay a console for not phone oh
okay check your base you oil nuts Kampf
yeah and that's configured yes correct
this this looks okay okay okay take a
look at the login page again sorry it
looks okay
ah okay we um go back into getting the
surrounding right okay so in the
beginning by when I was holding
communion so I had to like install
myself oh okay so I was wondering maybe
something did not contain I tried to
light this company this looks okay yes
this is not yeah it is okay okay maybe I
don't know anything okay
shooting so he needs help with the login
oh sorry test test right so can login
post
oh yeah posting to the wrong is 8000
okay some way it is uh yes so you need
to find something yes no not this one
this correct yes the silver post correct
but your base URL is not really
correcting yes it's not working
correctly
ah we start you're you're you're next f
often or not does back end the front-end
restart okay anybody else got issue no
oh okay
oh yes okay the other thing is stop the
nuts and restart again which is just
working oh we can log-in okay okay okay
I'll ask around
can you login okay you can log-in are
you able to login oh okay okay
you know track test okay you can log-in
are you able or you can you can login
right oh yeah uni-axial okay yeah okay
oh sorry I don't
okay you've got oh okay
you can login right okay okay okay
yes okay can start again okay well we'll
continue first and try and compete any
of you have problems later after the
workshop we will help to get it working
for you okay so now we come to routing
in max GS
okay so basically we are gonna see how
the routing goes on Knox Jess okay this
is going to be a Roman okay so you copy
okay there's a readme file to look at
read me - 2 dot MD ok so I think we will
speed things up by copying all and
creating all the pages ok so we create a
folder on the pages called dynamic a
pages / dynamic okay and then you create
some files inside underscores luck dot
view
okay and this file you can copy and
paste item number two
okay then that's another one under item
number four index dot view but oh wait
okay
they might just copy [ __ ] w underscores
like the view first
okay so should dynamic navigation hey
the Sun you don't you don't need to
login to to get it to okay so don't
worry yep
so once you get into underscores like
view dot navigation I saw it once you
copy in the pitch okay you the front end
is it running
okay let's click on this one okay go to
the left on the left click on the
dynamic rules what do you see
okay click on dynamic routes oh that's
all you see with
ah did I yes I think you number two
you copied the whole thing right yeah
okay see the pitch let's click on this
one it's not the view you see what's on
top okay you should be able to see the
rest
oh okay okay
are you able to see some links in the
page when you click on dynamic you can't
see give it
nevermind get back to you okay you can
see right okay so inside the dynamic
page one two three or this so when you
click on the one two three you will see
the header on top change as you click on
the page there's something wrong with
your site yeah do you rebuild hey those
who have something wrong stop the nuts
control-c and run the thing again we are
going on dynamic routes so they should
see a go to the dynamic menu item on the
left and then there's some you open our
picture you can navigate between the
pages let me go and just go around are
you okay
oh ho chicken together shit's problem
yes yes but lightweight click this thing
yes I will tell you why okay okay sorry
sorry
okay so when you navigate right just go
to / dynamic / one okay because the the
/ diamond pitch is not there that's how
you get a fall for error
okay so go / dynamic / one okay then you
can see some items ready okay so yeah
slaw so when you don't have the the
index page you get a 404 error okay okay
okay
yes yes is 404 because this is a a okay
when you click on the okay when you
click on the menu
it goes to /a why is getting a 404 you
go into the dynasty again there's this
function called validate this is one of
the next options so you validate your
parameters so sometimes your parameters
you only want integers you'd want
characters then yeah so you will fall
for you if you type in something yes
okay so you see that there's a validate
function inside the slug dog view page
there's the one that validates the the
parameters so if your if your indexes
are alphabet and not a number they are
four four yeah actually I fixed that
thing but I didn't somehow it wasn't
inside here okay so so much for it okay
no next thing you can create after the
underscores lock right you can create an
index dot view and then copy and paste
everything inside there and under the /
dynamic folder
you see that one is script number five
so this is actually the parent for the
for the dynamic Rob yes we can go to the
next ciao
oh my gosh okay okay yes so yeah okay
are you coming to that yes
okay so we have done the underscore slap
view and you have looked at the validate
function to validate the URL parameters
what happens if there's no parameters
will come to not so soon because of this
what happens if there's no parameters
you can that's why we you can create
index dot view file and then show
something or redirect them to some place
fourth or some other place okay so
that's what's the purpose of the index
dot file is four okay so next thing we
have this pager slash diamond then the
dynamic folder we can add one more thing
okay we can add one more thing / dynamic
dot view okay
so you have to dynamic here what's the
use of this extra dynamic dot view so
actually if you want to have a parent
page for all your diamond dynamic routes
like you wants a certain information
like you have a property page you have
something on the left that you one which
is common to everything inside there you
can put the this thing called enemy
review which matches the folder name
that is the parent and then inside all
the slap will be rendered by this nuts
child thing so your slap is could be a
different property like some hitch DVD
flat somewhere or some condo somewhere
it's all rendered inside it's just like
a layout justly oh yes but yes you will
have confusing here after that yeah but
you can nest it further so all the pages
everything the routes you can nest and
nests and nest yeah you can go dynamic
dynamic sub dynamic stops up Dominic how
deep you one yeah you can go but please
yeah don't know it's like wrapping high
other components yes okay
so error handling you see that 404 page
yeah this is quite important cluster
there's something there are there are
few ways to handle it okay so I think
I'll go through this quite quickly yes
okay so this 404 page the first method
is but you don't need to do this cake
cause it's not very good I will explain
it for for dot view you create 404 page
and then inside a nuts config there's
some configuration that you put in to
achieve redirect back there's some
problem with this and there's some
problem with this underscore dot view so
what is this underscore that view is
actually a wild card
so what cut is your fallback page so
let's say if you have a slash pages
and then underscore dot view cave you
type your URL slash some rubbish you
send you here
you send you two so it's a cache on but
his is better to use the bottom one
which the layouts slash error okay it's
actually a pitch although it is put
inside the layouts folder yeah and don't
know why but they just did that okay
and I think I will explain to you why so
that maybe it's better to and not the
code yet ok let me go to this okay so
what's the difference between this tree
the fall for error is a bit more
involved you've got to create the view
file and then you've got to type
something in the next GSK that's a
router property you have to do something
about it
the other tool they are easy it's ok
when you want to navigate between the
pages
ok so via the what is it okay so let's
go via browser URL so you type in blah
blah blah blah slash some URL ok all of
these cases will capture the error and
you go to the error page and you can
handle it but if it's a pushed a router
push it's not from the browser where key
in the root you push on the browser when
you're navigating the top two will not
handle it properly
you go to the default next error page so
only the last part it will handle the
thing properly okay this is for
server-side rendering how about static
page when you're using not generate same
thing okay same thing
this one will handle the error when you
push on the route and you also handle
when they type in the URL manually and
how they actually handle it is
okay when you're serving a page from
your from the host when that's the error
like s3 right as an error out you can
specify the HTML for that falls back to
so inside here there's some
configuration where you can state the
place to fall back to and you'll fall
back nicely to that pitch and you get to
see that now
yes blablablablabla okay but first
before we continue if that we'll look at
what Knox view is consuming right okay
so okay we have the layout for a thing
and we have the page so the layout
Kearney you are seeing only one layout
we will create another layout for the
error page okay so your error page one
supposed to error page the layout will
look different and we can go to read me
- read or MD okay we go to number okay
number one and two is we ignore number
three also ignore okay let's go to
there's one thing called nuts error page
create a foul in the layouts so later
you see the difference in the layout
okay layouts / mini-mall this is the
name I'll call it you can call it
something else if you want just remember
to use this the name Lita okay layout /
mini mode of view I can just copy and
paste the thing to the layouts folder
haha okay
okay
so we have created a layouts after you
create layout also inside the same
folder you will create the area dot view
this is a very special file name inside
the layouts because this where Knox will
go to handle if you have a error 500
error 404 yeah fine dress the server
side for for the client side you will
handle of course one of them they need
to configure and the host they're
serving the pitch the error dot view oh
you can overwrite it
yes I think so yeah I can override it I
didn't know exist how come on you mean
the next then that time uninstall it
wasn't there you know okay I think they
might put in that thing yeah cuz I just
prepared this I think less than a month
ago yeah okay so the error page once you
copy and paste very important okay is
item number tree when it's in a static
maps when it's in a static page
okay let's min
it doesn't
yeah yes so inside Lux config insider
generate keyword you have this fall back
okay if you set it to true yep
you will use the for photo HTML but this
one will go back to the error the error
error error page yes I think I set
something in the back end let me check
just check here because the back end
also needs to fall back where is it oh
crap okay nevermind I just won't have to
explain okay the sundeck okay okay so
this this is important if you are doing
the nuts generate later okay so we are
gonna try it out after this okay so
let's go back to the slide okay so once
you have copied those 200 is it's okay
no it's not design site because by your
web host
so you they'll fall back to a certain
pitch like whenever you wanted response
you're actually okay
okay so how to test it you go into the
dynamic menu again I think that's one
option where sisters are not found or
something click on it it should fall
back to that error page does it go to
that error page yes
thus okay yes so your seats you should
see a page not found slash using layouts
/ error view that is the error view page
that yeah you are doing okay so once you
have a some error with your routes
whether it's four four or five hundred
site it will come here actually about
the the static generator page we can you
might have some questions later I will
try and clarify on that pad okay because
I have not I I will try and see how I
can replicate that problem here okay so
also what you can try as you type the
URL you just type a rubbish URL on the
web browser it should bring you to the
error picture so
yeah mmm nope
yeah yes okay yeah
so if you have to type a rubbish URL we
also bring you to the error page okay so
now okay
this dynamic routing on a single page
application it is easily handled so sssr
how about static pages how do we do it
because this static pages is all pre
generated and if you want to generate
for every dynamic route for every
dynamic piece of data which may be in
the database and it can change you have
a problem so there are a few ways it's
not perfect but can be handled okay so
one of the ways that nuts actually or
less zoom in zoom that they show how to
do it ah nothing zoom oh okay yes so
inside January inside the next config
just the January properties that this
wraps okay and weapons is that there's a
function that's being caught you go to
our API let's say for example you want
to generate routes for all your users so
it goes inside here and then it finds
all the user IDs and then your generates
so if you have 1 million users
I don't know what and some of your users
change or things change it's not good ok
so yeah so what you can do is ok inside
that custom error page there's a few
things you can do you can allow the user
to click a link to push to some other
route that is known or you can drink the
mounting of the page you can route the
person to to the URL that is 404 key so
why prints is that ok let's say you have
a slash user slash essay Aaron
okay because this pitch is not generated
the static picture is not generative
because it is dynamic it will go to the
error page okay
and what happens is that inside the
error page because you can have this
information you can do a push okay push
to this place and if let's say I really
exist inside that would be good but
let's say if I do not exist so what's
gonna happen here I do not exist it's
gonna go back and forth back and forth
error
yeah so so you have to be careful how
you handle this I'm still trying to find
a way to see whether it can be better
handle so but the two ways that's so
five-figure is you add immediately
pushed by make sure you know that that
person is there or you click a link so
maybe in between what can happen is
actually before pushing you actually
check the database to find out that's
this person and then you push and if you
don't find a person then you show the
button to that say it's not found and to
go somewhere else that could be one
workaround okay so this is how the error
handling is done okay you can proceed
okay okay time for another okay this one
would be a very quick break
yeah I think don't trust this not anyway
the top that the top three react users
is actually Singapore India and Sri
Lanka according to the search yeah so I
pray in Japan is one of the Japan and
channels on the top users so you see the
blue color that's and a red colored
there's a difference you know where
which people use what a lot of Eastern
European companies use it I think yeah
yeah but one of my one of my colleagues
at angularjs right and then angular on
top view non-existent yeah but angular
on Google right and then this Google
search I don't know what they do whoo
okay let's go on
okay so nuts options and life cycles
actually we have gone through it but I'm
just gonna go to the owners shorebreak
okay five minutes five minutes
we have time yes five minutes you can
get a grab a drink or something
toilet break very handy for 34
there's an X event
okay [ __ ]
that means we end it for the showers we
have one are slightly less okay okay
is okay is it die okay not too heavy
going on yes actually but we use Knox to
generate the static there's another
option that I'll show you later
yes it's not just knocks yes you can do
static websites okay it's inside the
Knox options you can she put the header
or the meta tags and so on to generate
yes you generate those meta text for
each is different for different pitch
you'll be up yes you can put the same I
can put different yeah yes
yeah it was a bit heavy going in the
earlier panel
oh okay but
are you able to run it okay
Oh on the machines okay but are you able
to get a example running or something
okay
are you with her the Machine No ah yes
okay so actually if the the final answer
is all inside the yeah but there could
be some problems are so is better to run
it later and I see that it works yes
okay
okay oh yes yes public sites yeah
the short story on Knox is previously
the complainer worked is uh they're very
heavy into the public site so yeah
decide a static web sites was what they
were looking at because the SPS can I
can do sp
I'm gonna go but I went
okay another two minutes two minutes
to the developers plan would be keep
using reactor
being unaccompanied with the crank use
[Music]
it's the charge of abuse you
the network offers a lot
okay
[Music]
oh gosh okay
ah it's
yes okay
okay thank you everybody for joining
this far we are coming to the last two
stages okay I'll take a Slav question
sir okay so you go to the next life
cycle okay this is the nuts life cycle
which includes the server site but we
can ignore the server site if you know
the surface ID we are doing SPS they are
studying generator websites okay so
first thing is the incoming requests for
a pitch you get the headers whatever
canucks will work on it okay the first
thing it goes to is this thing called
NOx server in it so what does this thing
do actually okay so for react we have
Redux if of you you have you act these
thoughts but these thoughts exist in the
browser side so I'm going to transfer
order information from their food from
the server to the browser this is the
one right this one will do it for you
okay okay so and then next after that
yeah after the working on the store so
you go to the middle way read the next
config and then there are all the pages
then it will do the validation that you
see if it fails is the send you to the
404 page order fine yeah now for
something pitch okay and then so
validate we have released scenery did
this actually one of the knocks options
okay after that a sync data and fetch
okay so what are these two facing data
basically it's like you're getting the
data first in the backend before you put
it in the front end if you just as this
thing called data the data where you
store all your yo data
so it's on the browser side so this
acing data it gets all the things and
then it copies it onto the data yes
so for fetch similarly it will do a I
synchronous call fetch and then put
things inside your store
he was the difference between the just
not a nut server in it and this one here
not server in it if you do API call
inside there what happens is that you
take the API if if the result is small
it's still ok then you render the page
by the result is big you will go fetch
all the data populate so you take a long
time and then after that you render
which is may not be so good so just be
careful inside that the server side
please please try not to collect all the
data from the server side and then
render it it's like going back to PHP
nor you color everything so do it
somewhere else
ok do it somewhere else yeah I've seen
that mistakes happen so the the website
just takes a long time to load because
there's a lot of data they load it on
the server and it comes out ok so after
that render ok and yeah so I think the
big takeaway is about the loading of the
data
and this is again that's a yes so it's
not gonna be waiting anymore and for
every follow-up time this would still
get paper so we can load out whatever
value we see we can see in our developer
console platform or Firefox and whatever
we're logging out
yeah to debug here it's actually quite
pin pool but uh course okay yes so this
is that four SS are capable SP a you can
forget about this for ESPYs
yeah okay for static generated websites
what you do is you'll go through this
thing once to generate or your HTML
after that when you surf the pages is on
a browser is this I already so actually
this acing data this fetch missed is
quite useless there you just use the
mounted hope to do your course yeah if
you want okay so yes so now we go to the
nuts options here we have been to a
Singh data once running once on the
server and then every time you navigate
to the pitch is gets called it's the
unmounted you guys cool yes
fetch same thing so AG we are doing a
static pages right I think you don't
need to use those by we are doing SSR
yes you can use those it's just a you
Newland
so just be mounting splint okay so
somebody asked about how about the
haters or the things each different page
you wanna say more different header
there's this nuts option called hip so
you can put all your meta texts and so
on you can yes and that's one other
thing you can do does this think of
process is in sign next context which we
also go to process server equals to true
this basically tells ya on the server
side so if you see this you can don't do
your async fetch for very big data set
and you can put you can don't run your
window code inside here like event
listener okay so you run it on the elves
yes okay so yep
this actually scream button the process
server this is the most important thing
process dot server or process dot client
because you need to detect what is the
front rendered or a back render okay
layup okay so layout we've seen how to
use it inside the error view there's
actually a layouts property okay so this
way it changes the look of the layouts
to be different middle way and we use it
also for authentication scroll to top so
if you want to jump to the top page when
you navigate this is the one it's very
easy this one transition I can be
between page transitions validate we've
seen already validating the route watch
curious on a server side so your query
strings each time it's changes that you
can use this to watch the career change
and then do whatever you want with it so
far don't know what to do with it you
know
all right no man waiting of it will let
you know yeah but this will watch the
querystring change last thing is the
loading so if you navigate between the
pages or so that's actually a nice white
bar but you can overwrite it
yeah so the loading loading loading
thing when you go between the pages yeah
you can watch Karif oh okay
yes so we cover this next slide okay so
for Knox generate static web pages the
Knox server you need a Singh data fetch
basically they are and actually not much
use if there is no server inside Knox
generate because it's all generated once
and it's all push to the browser so you
don't need the distinct or no ESS are I
will show you what this is again there's
something extra to learn you don't need
to worry about SSR inside your plugins
okay because your plugins you need to
worry about SSR because you load your
plug-in which has a window component and
it renders inside the server 500 error
there's this thing called server
middleware okay so it's like you have
Express server in this middleware this
is running on the server side I frankly
I don't really like to use it but you
can read more is to run some server
thing inside but you can actually use
express itself okay so new life cycle so
view lifecycle that's created where it's
like component the amount then that's
mounted that's a before destroy and
that's update okay update is there
dangerous to use so weapons is that only
only the created hook is caught on the
server side yes the mountain and the
rest they are not
so we have to be careful that's only
created hook is in the server side yeah
Martin has no use okay so I think we can
zoom into the last line this one shows
something very important which is the
context this is one of the one of the
objects inside next yes so your user
agent where do you get your user agent
from so if you have a server-side
rendering and if let's say your process
server is true damage rending or from
the server side you can actually get it
from the request headers okay but if
let's say you don't have a server side
it's on the front end so you get it from
the navigator.useragent oh actually you
can not across I was just trying to
explain that inside that knocks January
you only can use the Navigator flag
because it's no longer yeah it's not
generating but this is a good
illustration on the server side in SS
arting so ssi eraklyon is quite a
headache but there are some advantages
to it okay so we move on yes so this is
a something that you should be aware of
we will see some problems okay let me
see
clean em mine yes okay so let's go to a
variable in server a maybe zoom in mean
okay we need to know what is rendered in
a client and what this render in the
server
okay sorry before that there's this
thing called Knox context so there are
actually a few things inside there is
not too difficult you can just go to and
see what is inside the client and
western side server so you need to find
out when a server client and know when
to use it
okay so sample what is available in a
server
the requests you know so oh you're like
you're authorizing took on everything
you can grab it from the header but so
if you're under SP a or so on sorry you
don't have it on a client you have this
window Navigator local storage so we've
used any of this inside the server
rendering page bye-bye local storage get
item inside yeah serve a pitch bye-bye
okay let's go next talking about the
problems but not seeing it in real life
okay
so the problems if the SS are yes zoom
in
sorry yes
actually don't eat but I just won but
it's okay
so uncreated hook is only run in the
server oh goodness
it is very difficult to see able to
build it yeah it's all run on both yeah
sorry sorry okay so okay the top if if
it's in a client okay you know it's in a
claim so the elms you are in the server
you can cut and paste this code and then
you put this window dot add
eventlistener click wait no it's it's
correct because my show the error yes so
if you are inside the server and you run
this window dot event listener you will
see the problem
okay I'm only talking about it but if
you put this code in you will see the
problem you it doesn't have to be even
this one can be any window thing you run
it in the server side it will blow up
okay
okay next design is okay this doesn't
explain it okay so next hydration
failure okay so yeah the Sun you also
get this error
they say hydration something let's zoom
into the coat okay we I hope you can see
okay so we have this thing called date
picker he is a date picker from the
front-end side okay what happens is that
okay you can scroll to the side shorter
left sorry left okay so if the process
in the browser then we require the date
picker component because this day
typical component inside there's
probably some windows event listener or
something so you only listen in a
browser but the problem is when you
render it in a server you cannot find it
because this thing only coming in a
browser
okay so you will get the hydration
failure okay we can zoom back okay
okay that means means the client site
when they render the whole Dom she right
the thing is not found this thing it's
not found so the service idea hydrogen
you want to explain your baptized yes
yes okay so yeah so the client-side it's
not matching the service that content
and then so they're called bailing
hydration blah blah blah so how to fix
it so you just wrap the component the
day typical with this no SS are ting yes
it's as simple as that
other that are you yeah actually that's
one more thing can do
does this be v if v if v if it's a huge
s in text so if V if is true you will
render that component if not you want so
you can do I think and do a V if na if
process is browser then you render the
component
yes in the server side you won't have
that thing yes so you come up yes and
she this SSR thing there's a few more
problems with it that I was working on
it's not if the pitch is slow to load
and then there's some things that are
happening you will see some really weird
things happening like you type on the
input you type one input but because
it's a HTML input and the CSS is not
yeah HDMI input the JavaScript has not
loaded yet you can type in but then
suddenly after the whole JavaScript
everything loaded the whole thing just
wipes out in the you you the string is
empty yeah there's some way to fix it
but I can remember about hope you don't
mean error it was something wrong that
that we did yeah and yeah and one more
thing
you have to know which one you want to
render and which I don't want to render
sometimes some of the blocks right the
HTML the the template blocks you really
need to like be careful where you want
to render the thing and then OSS are
actually helps does help a lot but that
means everything is still rendered on
the client-side which will defeat the
purpose of that yes right
so the Sun I mean there's are small
little things you have to be aware it's
not 100% perfect but you can manage it
yeah always manage it
maybe there'll be another topic that can
write about but so five not encountered
that that problem I didn't count it
about a year plus ago by yeah not the
place anymore yes so hydration error
kaida next one on this one is a error
depth
I couldn't there's no answer in Google
but we managed to fix it by trial and
error okay zoom in zoom in zoom in zoom
in zoom in so you have a store nuts view
GS door view Jess has this concept
modules for just also can have a store
for a user you can have a store for
product canvas store for something else
so you modularize it but the thing is
the aesthetic you create the file inside
the store for the what happens if you
have a component that you want to have
the component created dynamically and a
store called Dominic Li okay nevermind
this one that is available in a slice
okay so this store register module
actually is the one that you can call
the register dynamic store but the
problem is after registering I get the
problem that the state is not found not
found not found that state is not found
so what happens is that I actually
needed to have one more line below to
initialize the state again I don't know
why but this is happening so after I put
this in it's fixed because if I don't
have this listing below the comet set
counter blah you would not what this one
is inside your key I think this one we
can try it's inside your code another
public dot
you know public view yeah okay let's go
public dot view yes run in okay oh it's
not here
secured oh oh oh yes it is created
instead of create that function okay so
now you just open your console or f12
okay so that's this test and test and
you just comment out these two yeah just
comment out these two lines and then run
is just being run okay let's see okay
and then let's see what happens
yeah some problem already if it's some
problem is good yes I know this one may
not be carry fresh okay click on the
test ha ha
can I read okay so once you reload the
page right that's a button called test
you just need to click on it and then
the others button on the right test and
then use console you see the error okay
this was the problem you cannot even
increment the counter inside
okay you can comment it back and then
this tae-yong come in and see what
happens again case so anybody getting
error I hope everybody's getting our
error okay yes so once you are done
commented back uncommented back refresh
and click again it should work properly
I don't know why it happened I have no
time to dig into the framework so but
yeah Stalin era him yes we can go to the
slave and we can okay so everybody
uncommon and then try okay
yours okay magnificus so you managed to
get the error oh okay then come in
uncommon you manage to get the errors
right okay it's now uncommented and
click okay ready yes okay okay can okay
oh it's inside that same file there's a
con click yet click equals to test
equals to a double quote test yeah you
say you all okay can see the problem and
then I take uncomment it should be okay
yes so this one yeah I do trial and
error many many I think of I think
recess for many hours on this yeah I
refuse to accept that this thing cannot
work yeah but you need to do it for a
lot of things inside the state Canaan
one tip is the state right don't need to
put everything inside the state just
important things try not to use state
for everything
spin pool okay okay so now we come to
some interesting things but fortunately
is not happening anymore he so there are
some did have issues can zoom the thing
okay inside the Knux code right inside
some way inside a people found that this
single line takes three seconds yes so
you may have a lot of requests there's
going to be a problem so yeah a planet
it seems I think they fixed it in Knox
to the other one another issue is that
response read slowly after love
connections or so fits in nuts too I'm
not sure why but you can reach through
the documentation so one thing about
using frameworks is that you have to be
careful also because if these soft
things really happen it can be game over
if you are doing something big
okay our wish after day I'll show you
another one another static site
generator for UGS okay now
okay we skip through this one yeah yeah
because that crack company is gonna take
another three hours okay
some helpful stuff hopefully for
everybody you're next
okay so some performance tips so like
for images you can use the intersection
of the verb observers to load images
okay one example is that let's say you
have a country selector and you have
flex if you do a select simple select
you click open you have 200 countries
you have 200 flex flex loaded at one
time so this intersection of the variety
why you can do is you click you will
load like five flex which is the space
of the selector as you for example and
probably plus or minus five flex up and
also you look on a few and as you scroll
up and down you see it slowly loading so
you don't do 200 requests you just do a
few okay that's one thing code spitting
avoid clap using plugins if possible we
a discerner I need to find out why put
there was the reason
okay then languages that all can
remember it's been lazy lot languages
okay so like you have a language files
inside your application so if let's see
your ten languages
it's not good to load all ten so
previously knocks the there's an axe
i18n plug-in they didn't lazy load but
now you can lazy load service English
you know the English first then if it's
you switch to French your slide the
French so use the lazy load not just for
languages also for your components your
view components can be lazy loaded yeah
not only was required blah blah blah
okay my next
okay so view gs3 any breaking changes
coming up extremely minimal only one
thing sofas orders this loss thing so a
lot of people use losses like
I like one level higher on a component
so you can put some child inside a
parent note and then they change it to V
slot okay that's all his rest
it's actually very simple to do migrate
and for the beautified that we are using
her nice version one it's going to move
to version two which is not beta our day
everything once it's a more stable ok
the style the origin using this thing
called stylus hidden a problem if the
stylus is that there's some problem some
the person cannot maintain it or some
reason so it's like it's not very good
support so they are dropping the stylus
has not been actually main theme for
quite a while from y know so actually
you have to be careful with us of CSS
that we use when we are building
something that everybody can use
so actually CSS quite powerful these
days so well consider just sticking to
CSS there's a very big changes to the
initialization process of beautify so
this one I will also update so just to
take note because now we only in version
one yeah then next
okay so consider using the static types
fast loading SEO friendly easy
deployment ok know about SSRS PA static
sites ok and then this one crits um it's
like also a static site generator
Sambhaji
it's also going to do it when you are
big enough to generate this weight some
you said yes
we're in Singapore we have our I am okay
so I will place the slight link inside
the github repo can write because the
Sun a bit yeah okay I'll put the slight
links inside the github repo push again
later so y'all can have to look at the
slides yeah we are very sorry this
screen is very small but hopefully
everybody can still carry on yes thank
you everybody
if you have any questions you can ask us
or anybody else so so yeah okay I have
big thank you to Eugene and to Ashley
okay they are also using view GS but non
Maps because they need to use view GS
well yeah so they are very good also to
handle UGS questions yes okay so any
time can approaches yeah flows to open I
can stay here and until the next lesson
and water yes thank you very much